citizens of the reject Nation Greg here today
uh I'm going to be doing a first time watching
for a film that uh I was supposed to do a
couple months ago but just due to scheduling
because this is one of those videos it's going
to take some time to prepare just due to the
length of the film and the subject matter
and whatnot so I was looking for the right
time to to cover this and since we're going
to be out of town for uh the week of 13th
through the 20th figured yeah let's uh let's
do this let's we gotta I gotta get this up
for the end of the year I'm a little nervous
for for some reason just because of I've heard
how heavy this film is Schindler's List is
going to be watching Schindler's List today
if you guys can leave a like I know you can
that would be very much appreciated also um
full-length and watch alongs where you sync
up with your own copy of Schindler's List
I'm buying this off Amazon available for super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page thank you
so much to all who have trainers support to
us on our patreon throughout this year support
has not been overlooked sincerely thank you
so much okay yeah I'm a little nervous I don't
know why I'm nervous I'm a little nervous
Let's uh let's let's see what just it just
seems so you know such a heavy drama it sounds
like what I'm walking into but it's spelled
here it's a masterpiece let's see what's in
store
beautiful transition there
German forces defeated the Polish Army in
two weeks wow
it's already kind of got this like
fraught vibe
[Music] I knew this would be in black and
white but I didn't expect to see Schindler
capture with this film Noir quality bring
them over a round of drinks
you can say they are from me I don't know
anything about this man other than like the
semi-general story of what this movie is about
find out who he is yes sir
stay here
Schindler seems like quite a Charming Man
and leave a woman alone at the table in a
place like this [Music] what was this man
doing it's like winning over everyone at this
party that's Oscar Schindler
[Music] [Applause]
um it's interesting something tops between
feeling like cinematic Noir movie to almost
a historical documentary I'm looking for it's
extern
oh damn is that Ben Kingsley I didn't know
he was in this simple engineering though wouldn't
you think change the machines around whatever
you do you can make other things couldn't
you yeah once the war ends forget it but for
now it's great you can make a fortune don't
you think I think most people right now have
other priorities like survival you must have
contacts in the Jewish business Community
working here what community Jews can no longer
own businesses that's why this one's interesting
question but they wouldn't own it I don't
it huh they'd put up all the money I do all
the work what have you done Mama asking would
you do I'd make sure it's known the companies
in business I see that it had a certain panache
Nation
there's so much performance in Liam Neeson's
eyes alone in metal containers this is glass
it's not what I asked for my client sold it
to his client who sold it to the German Army
because of the freezing cold it broke this
is not my problem the German Army wants to
find out where it came from now it's your
problem
do you know where I can find a nice shirt
like that do you have any idea how much a
shirt like this costs nice things cost money
looks like you're in business man
[Music] foreign
wow it could not be better
oh tell me how on Earth could it possibly
be worse
thousand you with vegetable repair with 200
kilos of an animal about a month to begin
in July and to continue for one year not good
enough look we are living look we have been
put money still money mm-hmm how do we know
that you will do what you say because I said
I would damn what a way to take advantage
of a very unfortunate position it's outside
the ghetto so you can battle for extra goods
for eggs I don't know what you need with the
Polish work because you can't get it here
he's asking for 10 healthy women for a day
bring your sister okay you're a musician yeah
yeah I find a good hiding place if I were
you I'm not going to hide like some animal
the place is too high God this is so [__]
up I teach history and literature it's when
it's not essential
it's metal polishing this is an insanely well
made film
it's not right very good he's 53 years old
it's too new thank you you're crazy how many
times have I told you your work assistant
did you keep in your pocket at all times oh
he's I'm a metal polisher [Music] 's the MVP
of this movie huh filing filling keeping track
of my appointments shorthand typing obviously
a visual therapy all right please
this is masterfully edited
[Music] I love her just lean back it's got
taller just getting closer and closer to them
enabling me to profit with absolute confidence
and pride a full line of field and kitchenware
unsurpossible in all respects by my competitors
see attached to list and available Colors
oh Europe you're a clever Schindler my father
was fond of saying you need three things in
life a good doctor a forgiving priest and
a clever accountant
it's a good saying I'm trying to thank you
I'm saying I couldn't have done this without
you the usual thing would be to acknowledge
my gratitude it would also by the way be the
courteous thing wow Ben Kingsley is phenomenal
just like the conflict of working with this
man I'm so used to Liam Neeson performances
of the last 20 years it's fascinating to see
him play like a full-fledged character be
careful of the stepmis Mrs Schindler married
[Music] everybody remembers him he did something
extraordinary he set out for a particular
Legacy wound up with a different kind of Legacy
than planned in every business I tried I can
see now it was me that failed something was
missing if I'd known what it was there's nothing
I could have done about it because because
you can't create this thing what was missing
all the difference in the world between success
and failure whoa
that is ugly business man promise me Oscar
hello [Music]
today
oh my God they would have killed me but I
am essential to the war effort thanks and
to you that's great you are a good man hmm
don't ever do that to me again did you happen
to notice that that man had one arm did he
someone's feeling guilty him and Ben Kingsley
play off each other so well I have never seen
any movie like this of course seen movies
that take place during World War II but you
know nothing like this National priority that
Jews be made to shove us now juice shoveling
snow it's getting richer significance our
prick come with me I work for Oscar Schindler
a sexual worker for Oscars yes twice as useless
what the [__]
I lost a worker I expect to be compensated
if I had a grievance with the economic office
it's your right would it do any good that's
to believe the Jewish skate worker had a place
in right economics was a reasonable idea he
was a metal press operator
quite skilled so [__] up my plant manager
is somewhere on this train if it leaves with
him on it it'll disrupt production and the
armaments board will want to know why what
is your name my name is kunda hops
I think I can guarantee you you'll both be
in southern Russia before the end of the month
good day stand
stand [Laughter] there's some like real human
touches of humor here my apologies what if
I got here five minutes later then where would
I be
damn it's gonna destroy all this
foreign [Music]
can you see it that's not a villa I need to
turn it into the camp Stables the house it's
not over there
kindergarten 51. I just can't imagine treating
people like this just so this what's her name
and then here's
man the entire Foundation has to be torn down
in a report I'm educated too like Karl Marx
himself
what the [__] here are you sick bastard
it will take more than that I'm sure you're
right
oh Christ rebuild it like she said we have
more to see but we have only one more hour
of life [Music]
why are they doing this
gotta preserve it hide it
[Applause] oh wow that's funny good time
shoot him yeah
so diabolical
oh my God
[Music] holy God it's so horrifying
part of them death euthanasia
foreign
[Applause]
holy [__]
women
so sudden [Applause] thank you
[Music]
God damn it
why why
I can fit the girl but not you Mama I'm Coming
Out stay where you are I'd rather you be here
than who knows where
foreign holy Christ
oh my God I can get under the stairs they'll
be downstairsing soon he'll be safe there
hide under the stairs I've searched the building
there's no one here wow
oh my God what
[Music] thank you [Music]
fascinating it's like a Red Shadow that follows
her too [Music]
[Music] let's go please come on different
when you can see it huh [Music]
lucky oh my God
[Music]
ridiculously harrowing foreign
just like transplants you into this time man
monsters man [Music] this food does an incredible
job at throwing you into this CD hold harsh
ruthlessness of the Nazis and just that
desperate survival for the Jews like it doesn't
even feel like I'm moving a lot of times just
feels like capturing a moment in time
workers now the worst is over
hell they're not gone they're here they're
mine and they were going to be making so much
money none of this is going to matter it's
bad business thank you
just didn't make her a housemate huh you could
make things easier for me be grateful sucks
getting it's better with this guy sure I see
my cut from the factory owners in this camp
he wants his independence but Independence
costs money
God I [__] hate these people like you're
like real life monsters am I looking on you
see how you're doing you're a director don't
let Things Fall Apart I work too hard I really
hope he doesn't die foreign [Music]
come on man
oh that's very good but you've been working
since six this morning yet such a small pile
of hinges
I gotta be [__] me
crazy even here click it was the angle of
it maybe the pin this is
the machines were being recalibrated this
morning I was put on to travel in court come
on just hear him out
strange huh that's strange nobody knows who
stole the chicken
you committed this crime no sir but you know
who though
she shot the right guy I guess [__] hell
I just
it's treated like like they're nothing it
just feels like completely hopeless my parents
aren't washed off they're killing older people
now in Portia please bring them here I don't
do that whether another worker has certain
skills that's what I ask and that's what I
care about my father is an important not a
metal worker interesting how they frame him
but is under enormous pressure in normal circumstances
he wouldn't be like this he'd be all right
a man who loves good food good wine making
money killing he can't enjoy it yeah okay
somebody escaped from a work detail Outside
The Wire God lined up everybody from the missing
Command products shot the man to the left
I'll be his key the man to the right of him
25 25 people sick disgusting what do you want
me to do about it nothing nothing well man
husband and wife
[Music]
foreign [Music]
foreign
s from dinner
said to him why are you beating me he said
the reason I beat you now is because you ask
why I beat you
you want to shoot because he enjoys you too
much he doesn't want anyone else to know it's
a Jew he's enjoying he shot the woman from
the steps because she meant nothing to him
I go now man everyone has to just accept the
position they're in slave position they're
in but also live in a constant feel and fear
I could just die at any moment it's disgusting
you're nothing wrong that's a little control
controller's power that's power
like an enemy they fear that's because we
have the power to kill arbitrarily a man commits
a crime he should know better we haven't killed
and we feel pretty good about it will be killing
myself and we feel even better that's Justice
it's different than power speak his language
power is when we have every justification
to kill and we don't I don't think you can
convince this guy to do anything man
should I smoke you on the job tell her not
to do it again
kind of pardoned her I've been unable to remove
this change from my bathtub
coming down soap not life go ahead go and
leave leave a pardon you what what no this
guy's gonna Resort back
please don't shoot him
pure evil man
a little boy was just like trying to just
walk away like it was fine this is just evolving
into a sort of chaic Beast Specialties
again married down here you know listening
to everyone upstairs having such a good time
what's he gonna do I would like so much to
reach out to touch you in your loneliness
I mean what would be wrong with that so much
I mean maybe you're right about that too you
know maybe what's what's wrong isn't he's
going through his own head he's not even when
they compare you to him to uh verb into rodents
into lies I just no no you make a good point
this guy is psychotic he is paranoid as [__]
too he never talked me into it now didn't
you
[Applause] what the [__] man well registered
please thank you very much for the lovely
cake
oh wow
they must not respond well to this man [__]
they're gonna be aware of the Optics about
things they've got to separate the sick from
the healthy to make room
so ridiculously dehumanizing
look alive Rebecca [Music] so messed up pure
savagery this is one of the most horrified
things I've ever seen I think
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause] what is kids doing they're just
being taken away from their families [Music]
[Music] like that feeling of her relief to
think it's gonna Live Another Day
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so [__] up
foreign man
oh you gotta be kidding me
get out
I was supposed to get out when does this movie
become [__] about shutters lists
[Applause]
the suffering in this film water the water's
just right there you say we got your fire
hoses out here and hose down the cars thank
you [Music]
[Music] whatever he can help give them something
[Music]
clever disguising it like like it's a form
punishment every time the train stops you
open the doors you get the water yeah yeah
this car this car
what dude's gonna turn on you foreign
music in this film I kissed a Jewish girl
he likes good looking women he sees a beautiful
woman he doesn't think he's defending him
this guy was wolf very good looking he's defending
her and that's crazy
[Music] it's Ash [Music] ten thousand Jews
foreign [Music]
[Music]
coming back
that's the same little girl [Music] that's
when the change that really started to happen
with him huh some days this is all going to
end you know I was going to say we'll have
a drink then I think I better have it now
should I stay alive my people I want my people
who are you Moses I know them I'm familiar
with them I don't have to train them it's
good for you I'll compensate you that's right
it's good for the army look at this divide
I'll go along with it it's just irritating
I can't work it out look can't fathom that
he's sympathizing what's a person worth no
no no no no what's one worth to you
sir the children all the children all the
children how many 400 450. wow
[Music] yes NECA and one just touching
600. [Music] for each of these names you're
still working for me I'd expect you to talk
me out of it it's caustic new fault [Music]
all right it's whole time we didn't know the
list is an absolute good the list is life
yep
it's margins lies the cup Oscar there's a
clerical error here at the bottom of the last
page no there's one more name I want to put
there I've never find a maid as well trained
as heard of brilliant no way she's just going
to Auschwitz number two anyway what difference
does it not got Auschwitz never do that to
her no I want her to come back to Vienna with
me couldn't work for me there you pig you
pig you can't take it to Vienna with you next
most merciful thing shall take her into the
woods and shoot her Palace in the back of
the head just not a [__] like animal dude
I can't treat animal like that say your names
clearly they are the family dresdenas
Henry mancy and Leo our son hey oh boy yaakov
levertov irus [Music] it's interesting mirror
in the beginning of this movie
Coral bits Dalek actually something kind of
hopeful where would they go [Music]
everything's been so horrible I'm just want
everything to go okay
it's Hometown huh I know you've had a long
journey but it's only a short walk further
to the factory where hot soup and bread is
waiting for you welcome to brindlets
please don't let anything go wrong
not the [__] what's happening mama where
are we
they're in Auschwitz the train was never rooted
here a paperwork mistake was it a mistake
[__] um
[Music]
what the what the hell is going on is this
really gonna happen
[Applause]
is this really gonna happen right now okay
I think we're gonna cast we work for Oscar
Schindler who is Oscar Schindler we had a
factory in Krakow and then we were to make
a how old are you mother damn it get them
retrieve them why do you think I can help
you
could have you arrested and protected by powerful
friends all I say is I am not comfortable
with them on the table ah well said you shouldn't
get stuck on names
her people not names
foreign
polish the insides of shell metal casings
how else am I to polish the inside of a 45
millimeter shell Keys you tell me you tell
me Jesus damn sure's gonna get killed he's
gonna get [__] killed just making these
judgment calls like [__] there will be
no summary executions here dogs will no longer
be allowed on the factory floor without my
authorization wow he's got to ride such a
fine line with that facade huh no doorman
or meter D will ever mistake you again
but you're just waiting for him yeah I'll
tell Michelle's thanks shells rocket casings
apparently all of them have failed quality
control to be expected startup problems Stan
if this Factory ever produces a shell that
can actually be fired I'll be very unhappy
damn God you know like I'm happy about the
moral choice but is leading to this man's
death what day is this Friday it is Friday
isn't it is it what's the matter with you
you should be preparing for the Sabbath
I've got some wine
um
foreign
[Music]
do you have any money hidden away someplace
that I don't know about foreign
am I broke General Joe signed the act of unconditional
surrender
and the air forces in Europe to the Allied
expeditionary Force
the German war is therefore at an end but
let us not forget for a moment I think it's
time the guards came into the factory
at midnight you'll be free and I'll be hunted
I shall remain with you until five minutes
after midnight after which time and I hope
you'll forgive me I have to flee
makes sense received from his superiors to
dispose of the population of this camp or
you could leave and return to your families
as men
that really happened they really do that the
guards and [__]
in memory of the countless victims among your
people I ask us to observe three minutes of
silence
thank you Mr yeah
um I want that cloth distributed to the workers
two and a half meters each
it'll be done everything you ask
we've written a letter trying to explain things
in case you were captured every worker has
signed it
thank you
that's what it says forever saves One Life
Saves the World entire
laughs
[Music]
just
I love 100 people who are alive because of
you look at them
why did I keep the car 10 people right there
10 more people
this is gold two more people
one more person
ah
all right best
and I didn't [Music] guys so [__] heartbreaking
[Music] yeah
you have been liberated by the Soviet Army
we could use some food isn't that a town over
there
you feel real to me
good
[Music]
wow really [Music] oh that's cool I really
thought they were gonna kill him [Music]
foreign foreign [Music]
[Music] that's cool that they're doing this
[Music] no way
no way oh
alrighty well look guys I'm gonna pull up
uh IMDb here just so I have character names
in front of me uh yeah the uh what all I am
recording right I don't remember it recorded
yeah yeah I'm going all I can really do is
um just sort of talk from where I'm feeling
right now yeah I'm not going to attempt to
try to sound intelligent so for those who
already think I'm not intelligent go ahead
have a go at it in the comments um yeah obviously
like especially for a reaction it's a lot
quieter than I normally am didn't even have
jokes coming to mind I feel like it would
have been really inappropriate if sarcastic
Greg was popping off after in this particular
movie and uh it is interesting uh watching
this because I've been wanting to watch it
for a few months remember Community post when
I was like do I watch the history model or
dances wolves and people live for green Milestone
over that that was like months ago and there's
um a lot of anti-Semitism going on in the
media this these days so you watch something
like this you know like yeah [__] that
[__] this is This was um this this feels
like a film that is important this is something
that was so breathtaking like it's it's yeah
it shows the grotesqueness of it all it shows
how it's so grim and bleak and sorrowful all
kinds of depressing ass words you can throw
at it but not in a way that felt exploitive
you know it it feels like a like a big scale
personal project for Steven Spielberg I'd
imagine so I am curious to look up what awards
this one I I don't know if it wouldn't best
picture I I actually don't know what awards
this movie made uh garnered I was Blown Away
by it because you know it's one thing to hear
about things that are great it's not a documentary
it's it is a film at the end of the day but
that's what I mean by it's one of those things
that feels important because it really immerses
you into it you know like I I tried for my
end because I was aware I was in black and
white I was aware three hours so normally
we got these lights and they're like pointed
right at me and and I was trying to like push
them away so that way it could be a little
bit darker in here so I'm like brightening
up in the editing program I was trying to
give that experience but even with with that
I I found myself like just so so lost in it
it it's like beautifully depressing I don't
know because it it feels so authentic and
I feel like you know knowing facts about what
went down um in any type of horrible historical
event or even things that happened today like
hearing about it you know it's like obviously
if you hear about it versus seeing you know
footage that hits a lot different and here
they the the way Spielberg uses like the the
with the pacing and like John Williams did
the score but yet there's so much of the moments
like especially in the most harsh scenes uh
like when when they are just when the Nazis
are just taking all the Jews and just slaughtering
them or shoving them around torturing them
those scenes like there was no music there
and that that lack of Music creates such an
atmosphere and a gripping way to suck you
in to have this feel as close to feeling real
as possible the basic bit I knew was about
Schindler making a list to save Jews that's
all I really do I didn't really know much
beyond that and then so watching this so it
was like two hours and I was like what is
the saving of the chew's gonna happen when
when's that gonna go down because this is
so this is so hard to sit through I don't
know why that's like um bored or something
it's it is just it it felt like it hit on
such a a way that didn't feel like I'm watching
Cinema if even though this is like pure Cinema
it hit on a way that I I felt like I was watching
a I was experiencing something and I found
myself going I'm craving a bit of catharsis
here to start getting on like a heroic path
and yet the the cleverness of of I think the
execution of it is like you sometimes you
cut away from um Oscar Schindler for so long
and you're in the the depths of the experience
of being a victim in this war and so you're
seeing like the depravity of the Nazis the
soullessness of them and then you're experiencing
the uh like Helen has that line about accepting
you know the position she's in and it's like
yeah it's like you you see the way it's depicted
here how there's a you get if you're in the
muck of it if you're on the the end where
the Jews were at there is a point where I
imagine at least from the way the movie was
doing it where you do feel like a sense of
acceptance over it but that doesn't mean it
eliminates fear it doesn't mean it eliminates
the anxiety and the worry you know the the
fact that you die at any given moment for
no reason thank you and capturing that is
the thing that motive like because you get
to feel that and then when you do cut to schindler-like
scene the girl with the the one where they
put her in the red dress
which I imagine
it's red so I'd imagine it would symbolize
the uh you know like the Bloodshed during
the Holocaust but also as as a point because
like he that the needle starts to um to move
for him in that moment internally on the situation
at hand with eyeing her but then when her
body is dead that's when it really propels
when he sees her dead body that's when it
really propels him like he's got to really
start making a difference here like he's really
affected by it and that's kind of what I mean
is like it in a way with and I don't know
if this is intentional or not but you know
like Schindler is like yeah I can make a profit
off of War I get the factories going but I'm
not really privy to all the Terrible Things
the Nazis are actually doing like the actual
slaughtering and the torture I'm not really
privy to what's going on there so you know
like if he keeps a barrier he can just go
about his work but then when you know he's
actually witnessing it and then he's connected
to I mean yeah there's like the horrors before
him when he's when he's on that horse like
men on a hot horse on these are the [__]
before him but then when he sees that little
girl you know like that hits on a different
level and that's kind of what I was talking
about at the beginning of this discussion
is like it's it's one thing when you hear
about things but then when you when you experience
it when you connect to it like it just hits
you in a much harsher level you know and uh
yeah when it comes to real life tragedies
I'm gonna try to be as like respectful as
possible because that just hits me harder
than anything else honestly like that that's
the stuff that hits me the worst you know
and knowing it's real like knowing this really
happened like I'd be curious to go through
like what you know like fact versus fiction
like what what parts of these are changed
uh for the purposes of narrative storytelling
I'd be curious to go through that I I don't
know the the parts where the the Six Million
Jews were killed that really happened and
witnessing that here like that oppression
and the slaughter it just angers me oh my
God I just thinking like it was so it just
breaks my heart it's uh it's heartbreaking
and then you know it's it's when you connect
it to today and see what Jewish people have
to go through it's it's funny it's ridiculous
it's [__] awful
like it really is
anyway sorry I've I've a few Jewish friends
and uh yeah like just I don't want to bring
too much as much as I watched up a very political
film I don't worry too much it's just insane
how
so much of the trials and tribulations and
the suffering is very much ignored like it's
saying to me it's just it's insane anyway
back to the movie itself uh when the music
was there it was beautiful uh Liam Neeson
was excellent was he like a well-known dude
at this time because it's just kind of funny
when you think about like Liam Neeson the
meme today it's like I'm Liam Neeson my daughter
she was taken like he's always like a rough
Gruff Action Hero now and and then to see
his character here like I just believed Oscar
Schindler that's who I felt I was watching
this entire time and um the person in his
position being a German you know being a Nazi
and in his position and and then like there's
already such an ingrained type of you know
it wasn't like it he was instantly sympathetic
for the Jews it wasn't like he was instantly
motivated to be you know the Harriet Tubman
of sorts for the Jews like it wasn't that
wasn't the case for the guy it it was such
a real performance of the evolution of of
the choices he was making and like like when
he does talk to that um if you have a position
he made but that old man with the one arm
like he the idea of coming to terms with reality
of like these are this is a real person um
and then for him to be like being praised
or doing good when all children want to do
is just profit off of him and then profit
out like any of the workers during the war
in yada yada like to to to to get in touch
with his empathetic side for this situation
it was such a real performance like it felt
so so well done and even though you know the
change has to happen even then you know the
change has to come the way it seeps up on
you like when he does decide to get the parents
names of when the when that woman is you know
begging to get the parents over when she's
like here the Jewish people are safe
it it was such a natural transgression to
the point when he is crying at the end of
I could have saved more people I could have
saved more people I could have done more like
after all that he gets to the point where
he is the one putting his life on the line
and he's even sort of exposing and admitting
to it in front of the the guards you know
he is putting his life on the line this whole
time for that like it's like I don't even
want to make bullets that will actually kill
someone in a war I don't wanna I don't want
to succeed in doing that and and that to know
that like I wonder if that is true those were
those were Schindler's last like the last
thing he laments with the with the people
there um because like there's something so
heartbreaking and beautiful about that that's
how I feel about my YouTube views I'm always
like that could have gotten more like to think
about like he just did something beautiful
and amazing and he and he went against his
all the conditioning you know and he changed
but all he thought about was how there's more
I could have done that's powerful that's powerful
he was great his chemistry would Stern like
that's such a heart of the film Ben Kingsley
and him that's such a heart of the movie of
you know because even Ben Kingsley doesn't
trust him or doesn't take much of a liking
to him knows he's just being kind of used
but then you watch as Stern evolves opening
up to him being a little more vulnerable to
him showing that you know you're the Schindler
guy ain't such a bad guy after all and seeing
that there is such a greatness in him like
the evolution of their friendship is something
so beautiful and Ben Kingsley just knocked
it out of the park like wow phenomenal we're
talking about acting though like the scene
stealer as ugly as this is It's a mid it's
refined like he is so evil like he he is the
definition of evil and he does the performance
so natural like it's it's insanely believable
how evil and morbid and disgusting and repulsive
this individual is he plays him so human which
makes it that much more unsettling because
you never know what this guy's gonna do you
just never know if he's just going to be like
I'm annoyed at you so I'm going to shoot you
he was um he was like a phenomenal performance
it's a phenomenal performance like the three
main there's a lot of great stuff like every
one they cut to felt like I was watching a
real person like the three main guys in this
movie they absolutely Excel but to the entire
Supporting Cast every time you cut to them
I'm like did they hire an actor or did they
just hire a like a real just some like a a
Jew with some experience or something like
that I don't know you know what I mean like
where they didn't want an actor for this day
they just wanted a real person like if my
mind would sometimes go there because obviously
like one of these when the movie was shot
there's no way they could have got his own
from actual World War II to play these controls
but I'm I'm saying like it there was such
an authenticity at least the way it registered
that it felt authentic I wasn't even thinking
like who's this actor because they they were
just so believable like everyone was very
believable it's insane the cinematography
is excellent you know there's there's a lot
of the the way the the shots are from Silver
doesn't usually go like super handheld and
I felt like I don't know if half this movie
is but but it felt like close to half of this
movie was handheld which I thought was a really
uh great choice that it didn't abuse the handheld
choice and it was used at all the right times
and it does it would hop back and forth between
filming like you know uh like certain shots
that definitely felt like a Spielberg movie
but never in a way that felt like Grand and
full of wonder the way you associate a spillwork
movie to be like I feel like it was really
pushing against being that to feeling just
incredibly real like honestly if I didn't
know that this was Stephen A lot of the time
there's a way with the way Spielberg shoots
movies now especially in the last 10 years
or so can't quite put it into words but they
all look like a Spielberg movie to me like
the way the framing is done and the lighting
it there's they look like a Spielberg movie
and if I didn't know Spielberg directed this
I don't think I would have I don't think I
would have guessed he directed it yet there's
still some of that Master Craftsman [__]
at craftsmanship at hand uh with the legendary
still Steven Spielberg this was a beautiful
experience and and not an easy one a very
uneasy one but you know like I it's this one
has come out 94 93 same year Jurassic Park
came out did I know that for Friar man Spielberg
is something else first Jesus uh 93 yeah for
a movie that came out in 1993 doesn't feel
dated one bit not a frame of it feels dated
this does not feel like a movie made in the
90s it's decades old and it feels like if
like this came out today I would I don't even
think of it in that frame until now like this
came out in the early 90s I didn't even look
at it like that this doesn't feel like a movie
that was made it feels like a Timeless classic
I'm really affected right now I'm really uh
uh that was inspiring I'll never be as good
of a man as Oscar Schindler that that was
there's inspirational qualities but it's it's
one that you know and with it talks about
theme with themes about um I know I'm just
kind of rambling here with themes about like
the power to because they did some moments
where they would like mirroring Ray finds
and and Liam Neeson where I don't know it's
kind of what was the was the was the visual
directing language of it trying to say that
because like they go into business together
and blah blah because they talk so much about
the power of choice to take a life and that
whatever that line is um when he's talking
where he finds when he's drunk the whole thing
leads to the whole pardon bits that she'll
learn some other world could have gone down
that path but it's it is so much about like
the power of choice because Schindler could
have easily just turned a blind eye shouldn't
there could have easily just not done anything
he could have just gone about his business
and and said yeah I'll just those are the
Nazis I can't disobey them like he he went
he went against the grain and he made a choice
a bold choice and so this is so much about
the Power of Choice and I think that that
beautifully resonates throughout and you know
they talk a lot about us and there was a a
man full of gratitude and and I am very grateful
for this movie I'm very grateful for this
because this is something that feels like
I said it feels important educational and
um while tough experience kind of a necessary
one I think to to sit through you know like
shouldn't shy away from it end the day I didn't
go through this most of us did not go through
this but there were a lot of people who did
so coming to try to understand what it's like
the best way you learn from anything is try
to get a bit of that Human Experience feel
to it and I and I feel like this really provides
that that Human Experience so yeah anyway
this was an interesting one thanks for being
here happy Hanukkah Merry Christmas that this
video should be going out uh like two weeks
before all that right I think so I'm not sure
feel like it'd be really inappropriate if
I released
I will release this way before like at least
a week before then [Music]